team garyvee just texted questions and
the stress goes you sipping tea King
Gary
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
just promoting a little uh little event
I'm doing with Matt Higgins
on LinkedIn I posted good morning
everybody hope everybody's super well
really appreciate you being here with us
this morning let's get right into it
today's only an hour unfortunate because
I have some business to attend so let's
get right into the show obviously like
always take a screenshot share it on
Twitter sharing on Facebook good morning
good morning taki or Shane nama what's
good Tyler I'm really very hard yeah
good morning guys what's up yeah my name
is Maria Legarda and I am an actress and
a content creator and I'm Daniela varta
I'm a singer and a concentrated so we
were here today because a big part of
our brand is together as well if we have
our own separate brands if I'm an
actress and she's a singer and um last
year was the hardest year of our life
where we went through severe depression
anxiety after losing my brother all
while having to do it in the public eye
in the brink of our career taking off I
have just booked an amazing series here
in her state she was on tour so we
really persevered through that we were
able to start a non-for-profit
organization and the name of my brother
in Colombia open up our own a clothing
company I mean we've been really really
doing great in our careers as content
creators we have millions of followers
everything is going good so our biggest
question for you now is as my sister
told you we are already very strong in
the Latin market we want to figure out
how to be able to cross over into the
American audience and also reach the
Latin ex without neglecting our Latino
audience that we already have what do
you recommend how can we do that we also
want to be able to show the brands that
you know we have such a low following we
have fans that will buy what we promote
what do you recommend
so what's great of all I'm sorry about
the passive new brother I'm sure that
was be ridiculously difficult on
congratulations on everything I mean you
know the good news is you know Becky G
and bad bunny and they've we've proven
this already like this you can cross
over not neglect you know the the base
and easily play out that you know
Spanglish Latin kind of crossover play
it really is truly a couple of things
one it's patience too because really it
is patience it takes time right yeah
like
you know I love everybody's like Oh bad
bunny and like you know people that talk
of a bad buddy been [ __ ] with them
for five years right so like so like for
me I think it's a couple things one
similar to let's just use bad bunny or
Balvin or or any poor neck Nicky Jam it
is about collaboration with us
superstars there's so many us actors
actresses content and definitely music
right that desperately want to tap in to
the Latin culture so they need you as
much as you need them so I think it's
having the humility and the tact to
reach out to some of those artists that
you want to collab with right whether
it's skits on IG TV or YouTube with a
Fame you know with a famous actor or
actress or whether it's obviously a song
and a collaboration I genuinely believe
that at the level that you're playing at
it is collaboration crossover the brands
will come the brands thing let me tell
you exactly how it happens we put Becky
G in our Super Bowl spot this year for
sabra right like you know it once you do
that then everybody's considering you
all the time it's just one moment in
time and so I I wouldn't pander as much
to the brand play I would pander much
more to the artists that can help you
cross over and I would do a ton of
collaborations YouTube stars
tick tock stars and and obviously actual
actors and actresses in your field that
that have more of an American audience
yeah do you recommend for example like
in tick-tock right my audience my
American audience is second heaviest
after my Colombian audience do you
recommend that we start in our tick-tock
and Instagram also dropping like just
English content ourselves cuz that's a
really big part of us I mean we were
raised Wars of course but we don't want
to I feel like when we do it our Latin
audience is like no no we want we want
horse of course
so no different you know that's the most
extreme language and I see it every day
and my answer whether it's someone in
Asia or someone in Colombia or somewhere
anywhere else is post one more time a
day okay like literally making a video
right now being with guys we're going we
we're ambitious girls and we're going
there so here's what we're about to
we're gonna post more often and
sometimes it's in Spanish and sometimes
it's in English and sometimes it's gonna
be in Spanglish the way we actually
talks
yeah you know I'm Russian you know I'm
with my parents right now we start the
sentence in Russian and we end it in
English right
so yeah I think you post more so and you
make the announcement that you're gonna
post more so that everybody doesn't feel
like they're missing out anything also I
would 100% when you do English content
paste somebody it's not expensive to
transcribe it and caption it in Spanish
okay so just yeah because we put
subtitles on everything right good
recently started doing it in order to
write yeah we do it we'll do it in
Spanish and we'll do an English but
we're just trying to figure out how we
can target more the our culture of the
Latin ex and really just go there with
the English community without making our
you know people feel neglected you've
got this
you know transcribing captioning
collaborations and more content you're
set a whole audience is asking for your
social handles so what's your tick-tock
and it's mine I am Miss Legarda on
everything and I am Daniela garden spell
Legarda having fun le g8r da good luck
ladies mmm tea is good this morning
collabo is the key Lloyd Berkeley thank
you so much for joining us Kazakh what
is good what about Aussies what number
do we need to text caz we're gonna start
taking people from the Twitter is where
we're gonna start pulling international
people from 40 with Gary B so if you
have a question please go to twitter and
hashtag it tea with gary bj how are you
it's great to see you again no energy
here from New Jersey it's great to see
you I have a big H a your your audios
are here muffled any way to fix that you
think okay it is a hair better keep
going okay so I'm a six year 62 year
young entrepreneur and one of the things
that has been amazing
so I do have a question for you yep
story - it is for the past year thanks
to Claude inviting me to come into
vaynermedia and then working with Dany's
and all of your peeps over there for the
past year I've been embedded in
vaynermedia working with everybody on
their well-being this little machine
over here at this body composition
machine the reason I reached out to you
is because when I started watching your
videos about what to be doing with
Michael Jordan and it so what we're
doing in been strong I mean your well
being
yep seriously what you know you guys are
doing over there so twice a month I'm at
vaynermedia I've now had the opportunity
to be with over 500 of your themes and
really not just what's been interesting
has not been just I'm talking to them
about the body composition but in this
conversation or finding out kind of like
where the thoughts are what they're
going to do where they have challenges
and what's great is we have the data but
it really becomes a conversation about
what could be one to create my life and
one of them amazing if a duck from your
team is I was a little I would ever play
I was a little concerned when I was
there I'm like okay I'm 62 these guys
were all young I deal well with people
that are younger but I was like maybe
they won't give what I have to say and
what I found is a generosity of
Millennials with people that have other
experience I think there's an amazing
opportunity to create and collaborate
I've heard you say that in different
conversations able to be interviewed but
you're going over there so my question
that is during these challenging times
um during this window of opportunity
what do you see instead of people that
are older that think that they can't you
know they don't know yeah again
what do you seize an opportunity to get
more people that are younger and older
in all ages was kind of like ageless
entrepreneur ISM how do you see that
being something's being able to do a
catalyst for change and creating
opportunity
yeah I appreciate it and I think you you
know obviously you you follow closely
and you've been in under the roof of our
culture in the office and so I'm I
believe the generosity that you're
feeling is that my organization knows
that if we're gonna be woke and we're
gonna be so amazing this is not just
being open to other
people's you know races sexual
orientations lifestyle choices I think
no question the number one group of
people in our culture right now that are
underestimated and suppressed for what
they can bring to the table is me over
fifty five set I mean people completely
in at least in my world are completely
under estimating the impact the value
the wisdom you know the jokes of like
not knowing how to use technology
I laugh listening you know my my
organization is quite liberal and very
loving and and I love that I love the
warmth that comes into our organization
but the one place they don't see it is
they wildly underestimate 4857 6371 8284
and so I think there's a lot of ageism I
really do and it's a it's a passion of
mine and we're starting to hire that way
you know we're going through a ton of
resumes and we're gonna start hiring
creatives and strategists that are over
60 you know I you know you live in
Summit New Jersey which is a nice suburb
of New York City we know that there's an
extraordinary amount of retired actually
have finished their careers at
executives from the heyday of AD world
who actually just woke up and said wait
a minute I'm 63 years young I'm bored
who we can hire them at good prices cuz
they're gonna be thrilled to me and
energized and do something now they
don't need the salaries they used to
make and work and we're excited about
the impact they're gonna make on our
youth culture this is let's use this
video as as a he to action if you're 50
to 90 and you feel like you still have
it you the answer is you do like if you
actually have the hunger to produce an
impact this is an incredible time and so
you know to answer your question
directly I think they need to be
producing content at scale you know
videos on LinkedIn and YouTube about
things that are forever true J you know
like like they're it's incredible to me
how many things are true at 44 that I
learned at 22 32 37
you know and and then that goes on and
on and on and so it's
it's literally just a perspective you
know there's so many people that dwell
and think they were born into a bad
situation and instead of seeing the
opportunity that the dirt under their
fingernails allow them they decide that
the Machine and life is unfair and
they've been handed a bad hand and they
don't know how to play that hand and and
the reason poker is such a game that I
think attracts people to it besides the
math is it's a game of life you can get
you know a 7 a 9 offsuit and navigate a
victory and we see that in the world all
the time and that's kind of how I see
ageism right now I don't get you know I
know this about you jcu navigating
through social I know the impact you've
had in the office like you live another
40 [ __ ] years like what are we doing
here I don't understand that people to
understand they're at halftime they
think it's over you know and I'm blown
away by that
and a I want them to start realizing
that they've got decades left and B I
want the 15 25 35 and 45 year olds that
are watching here to realize how much
value they can extract from the
individuals okay your grandma or your
uncle or a mentor may not know how to be
crunk on [ __ ] tick-tock but they can
teach you a ton of [ __ ] that you will
not know for another two decades so I
hope they're inspired to make it's about
putting it out the big thing I talk to
people because I get a chance to
navigate and help them in their
well-being watching I watched every one
of these episodes and what was
interesting was and it's funny because
the other day when we did the thing with
this bar of bar nine I got so inspired
because I've been speaking around the
country ever since Biggest Loser and
with you it's you know being a speaker
when you get in front of an audience
it's empower for you pull up their
energy but when I'm with people
one-to-one and pull off their energy and
it's really trying to do see video it
was like this being weird because I'm
like talking to the machines but what I
found was and I called respect they said
look I gotta tell you what Gary said
made some extensions like exercise
doesn't feel comfortable first time do
it but after a while you feel better
about it and if you come to your place
what you're giving to somebody then you
don't obsess about like how do I look
and how to like
i 100% got new year as most people know
me for healthy well-being but I've lived
my life is a frickin Hobbit entrepreneur
I've been in startups I've been in I've
been have where any directives were
still you know a corporation and I'd
have reflected back up and I wasn't
speaking about my business
entrepreneurship what's going on thank
you you're welcome brother I'm gonna try
to get to a bunch of people today so I
only got 45 more minutes I'm gonna jump
up a little early but I appreciate that
and that's what happened with me with
wine you know Jay thanks for being on
everybody that's what happened where Jay
just said is what happened with me with
wine like you know I was like wait a
minute I want to talk about
entrepreneurship in business that's what
I've actually been my whole life I've
been a entrepreneur hustler
you know Grindr flipper businessman long
before I was a wine guy and and even
though that's what I was first known for
you could always make that transition so
if you're watching right now and you
want to be known for what you actually
are versus what and by the way I see
this a lot with attractive people both
guys and girls like they're known for
being attractive then they blew up on
Instagram but meanwhile they're there
they've got so many skills and so many
other things start making content about
what you want to be known for not what
the audience is giving you likes for
it's gonna lead to a much happier life
the reality is is that you know it's
it's not fun to be in the ecosystem of
just living for the like and so I just
really really hope people understand
that and yes you will get far less likes
you know when you're showing your huge
guns you're gonna get forty thousand
likes and when you're talking about
architecture you may get four thousand
when you're showing like a lot of skin
and look at sexy as [ __ ] and pop in you
know like you're gonna get a lot of
likes when you start talking about
flowers you may not but the reality is
you have to speak with your passion
about it's the only way to get to
happiness and there's a lot of people
unhappy right now cuz you're caught for
what they were known for and what they
popped off the way and now they're stuck
living for the likes let's keep it going
hello hello how's it going good then how
are you I'm good thank you
my question is I'm a graphic designer
and I'm really hard on myself and oh I
don't like what I create so I'll have a
really good idea I'm always stuck in
this mindset or is not good enough I
need to do better I need to keep
learning to improve and that's hindering
me ever invest in it what I want to put
out there so I just want to know how do
I get out that I can't mindset by
realizing that that means that you're
insecure to other people's feedback or
you grew up in an environment that you
know put you into a mindset whether that
was parenting natural DNA or the
neighborhood you grew up in and the
people you surrounded yourself with and
and you have to realize it's a ghost
you have to realize it's a ghost you
you're you're not right and more
importantly everything is subjective
everything is subjective there is no
right when it comes to art the reason
I'm so fluid with what I put out is some
people think it's the greatest and some
people think it's dog [ __ ] some people
think I'm repeating myself over and over
I think other people think that I'm so
convicted in my truth that it's
inspirational my man listen to me the
reality is is get out of your own
[ __ ] head know that it's a ghost it's
a ghost it's not true it's complete
insecurity it's complete insecurity and
the way you get out of it is practice
okay you know you've got to you've got
to get in you've got to find a way to
just hit enter and walk away
you know you're to just ship it like
it's it's a [ __ ] ghost it's not real
it's not I promise you okay so if I want
to put something like if I create
something I want to get a physical
version of that is it just a case of
just do it and you don't know just do it
and are you looking to sell that
physical version looking to put in your
house uh a bit both really cuz that's
all about learning to you know I'm sorry
I apologize I kind of like to have the
insecurities oh I want to buy something
for myself so like an hour print for
example but unlike it's not good now why
should I buy it
you know it's interesting I what I what
I think is you you know for yourself you
get to just decide you're the judge in
the jury but for the for the world do
not judge for them you know you you you
don't get the judge for them that's the
reality it's funny I've been working
with my best friend on this thing wine
texts that I'm sure you've been hearing
me promote for my dad you know yesterday
we went through 500 different wines to
buy you know and I and I watch Brandon
and he overthinks things and I'm like
Brandon we don't get to decide if this
wine is great or not great it's the
consumer you know and the reality is
like for example today is gonna be a
Pinot Noir
it's a $52 Pinot are that we're gonna
sell for like under 25 bucks that's a
good time
Dustin put up the wine text is a perfect
example though but it was a good
discussion and maps yours what I'm like
Brendan you know I like this pinot noir
style you don't like this pinot our
style Rick does Jeb does Steven doesn't
it's everyone has their own palate yeah
and you need to realize that Ben that
it's you know that you there's audacity
in you thinking it's wrong or right you
need the humility to realize they get to
decide not us yeah so it's just a matter
of whatever I do really has to be good
enough for me is just subjective whether
whoever I put out correct
somebody's gonna always love it and
somebody's gonna always help hate it
this is coming down to you leaning into
two core things humility and self
confidence everyday humility
self-confidence you middle II you should
make a [ __ ] piece of art right now
named humility and self-confidence and
pin that [ __ ] on your [ __ ] wall and
look at it every time and see this
[ __ ] face and then just make it post
I'll pre you face next to it and then
there'll be my daily inspiration and
I'll buy it I love you buddy take care
Cheers
a kid like that did I'm always gonna be
yelling I left somebody stop yelling at
me Gary I got good news for you I'm
gonna be yelling to the [ __ ] end of
Earth that is what I'm going to be doing
cuz that yelling is coming from the
sweetest [ __ ] sweetest kindest caring
this place you could ever imagine it
might come out Jersey it might come out
Alpha it may come out like a competitive
[ __ ] like I am but I promise you where
this [ __ ] comes from where
[ __ ] seed comes from is the [ __ ]
sweetest kindest most empathetic caring
sympathetic [ __ ] energy you'll ever
taste let's keep it going
hey Gary come on me
good morning Kristen so I'm I uh no
sewing company in Nashville it's been
growing for the life I'm just gonna jump
right into it um it's been for the last
like four and a half years or so I've
bootstrap from the beginning I've like
taken up as little space as possible
and now finally like signed a lease on
March 1st for a huge space need every
bit of it when it's busy
my sewing company caters to
entertainment all of my exactly so then
on March 3rd we had a tornado but like
blow right by my window um miss my
business knock out like all kinds of
other businesses homes and everything
like f4 tornado back so for a week week
and a half everything was really
shattered and then we jump straight into
Kovac quarantine so all of my contracts
cancelled needing needing any kind of
sewing for the next like six months
I think festivals even picks up June
July August somewhere around there I'm
so cool like two weeks to go week and a
half ago I sent you an email and I said
all right I'm gonna do exactly what you
say to do and I'm going to go full out
and I had already started like I built a
website that had nothing to do with my
Nashville based business I just felt
like my name com all of the things that
I love and I'm in a document and
Chronicle like every step of what I'm
going through and learning like in terms
of sustainable fashion in terms of
entrepreneurship in terms of like taming
my Mustang horse and all of these little
things right
few days later the Forbes article comes
out saying we need help selling masks
and I was like this is gonna cost me a
lot of money and if I'm gonna go out of
business like I just I felt it like I
knew that this is what I needed no way I
knew it was right yeah exactly and I'm
like you know I'm not just I can already
feel your energy not just as a wonderful
human being from altruism but also
having those instincts of amount
recording our nature and saying you know
this is the right thing to do yeah
and if God willing something nice comes
out of it on the backend then Phil being
there not so be it
exactly yeah it wasn't like everyone
masks yeah isn't there like such a fine
line between chronicling and documenting
exactly what you're doing because it's
the right thing to do right and then
doing it because you want people to see
you doing the right thing like I mean
look what you know to your point one of
the things that confuses people about me
so much especially my assistants that
people are close to me is I'm doing all
these nice things and I don't bring them
up at all right you sent me perverse
months it's changed my like my whole
month thank you
yeah it's keep going so anyways so yeah
I started documenting it and I was like
I was posting to tik-tok everyday I was
posting to youtube I was listing to
LinkedIn like the tutorials went on on
YouTube the the crystal what's your
website so we can throw it up here while
you're talking
Oh crystal Douglas calm just the way
that my name's I know anyways I did it
and it blew up um I ended up in the New
York Times I ended up on NPR like all of
these things and I was like I didn't
expect that and then the contract
started coming and the way that I and
yeah I've been sewing like 14 hours a
day and I got all of my girls back to
work and the way that I structure my
company everybody says that I paid too
high I pay high because that's what it's
worth because I do the work and I know
exactly what it takes
so my your business you like I pay too
high to like I mean I paid too low
sometimes they say like who gives a [ __ ]
what they say that's not that well
anytime somebody tells you you're you're
paying too much you tell them look
you're dead in the face and just say
that's very sweet
you worry about your [ __ ] business
okay like Gary you pay too much here I'm
like they're like no you're paying too
low here on my part and there's 47,000
creators that I can hire it's applying
to me like it's not super complicated
you know like like I get to choose like
you get to run your business Sally
yes exactly there really aren't a lot of
things just isn't national yeah there's
not having anybody tell you anything
about your business is similar to
anybody telling you on how to raise your
kids it's a joke we
me included we can talk in the macro but
in full detail like you you know that
that gets silly because one knows there
unless somebody's asking then you answer
but you know I understand don't worry
about that don't spend another second on
that ever ever ever again in your life
don't overthink that because yeah now
I'm slammed because it's so funny is in
that initial email I was like if I fail
I want a job interview at Chattanooga
vaynermedia because I am doing exactly
what you said to do I swear if I go down
I'm going down leading the charge if I
get evicted I I want a job interview
that's what I want and I didn't fail so
you don't have to do that um my classic
film funny thing happens when people
actually do what I'm saying which oh by
the way is [ __ ] pretty advice and they
actually do it
yeah sustained period of time most times
they do not fail sometimes people don't
have enough talent and and they're
delusional about what they're up to but
if they follow it it's so tried and true
it's so trite or true I'm so proud of
you
if anybody's watching this and they're
scared to actually go pull out and play
fallout like I am no line on social
media and those videos have a hiring
20,000 views you don't I mean yeah I
mean look it's there's good it's just so
free it's [ __ ] free absolutely it's
amazing well my question yeah yeah it
was how do you balance the things that
you that you want to do versus the
things that you need to do but then when
I woke up today the question is now how
do I really build a profitable business
when I don't care about the money by not
building as profitable a business as you
could but still make it profitable
enough that it sustains it's how I run
my businesses and how do I make it
profitable enough where it sustains
itself because here I'm going on your
back yeah it can't be yeah you have to
be you have to be profitable or you'll
go out of business right if you want to
be charitable and this this might work
for you because this helped me if you
want to be charitable be charitable as a
human being with the profits you make
okay if you're true if your charitable
within your business there won't be a
business okay
yep now I got it you see what I'm saying
could this really help why I struggled
with it I I did my charitable work
within my business I didn't fire people
that deserve to be fired I did a lot of
things and then I realized well if Wine
Library goes out of business and then
later if vaynermedia goes at our
business I'm not doing anything for
anybody so let me get this profitable it
hurts but I transformed into having that
decision-making capability I've always
had it
I never was under water I never was
losing money but you have a little bit
of a nest egg to sustainable business
and and then I I do a ton of things I'm
very proud of with yeah money after I
take it from the business so you're able
to do that as well
yeah I think I'm right there in that in
that like spying gray area of of you
know you let me want to smile
do you struggle with firing people oh
yeah let me let me tell you something
that really really it was bike it still
is and was by far the hardest thing for
me as an operator what you you'll be
surprised this is gonna hurt me saying
it and it's I think it's gonna help you
once you realize that that's your ego
talking it's gonna help you a lot
one of the things that happens with
people like us that I'm sensing from you
is you feel like they're better off a
theory that you can shelter them than I
did this all the time they're not good
so if I let them out into the wild
they're gonna really suck out there I
knew you were going to get this so the
reality is it's not true and what you're
doing is you're building up subconscious
resentment towards them which allows you
not to manage them properly and you
would do them a much bigger favor by
letting them go and giving them maybe a
little bit bigger severance package or
maybe in months to pay or something then
doing doing what you're doing right now
yeah okay oh you have no idea what I'm
walking away with I do know that's why
that's why that's why this format has
been so great right like you know not
having to be rushed and it kind of
trying to go for how fast the impact
like I do on a podcast or a scary be
like by spending these few minutes I
could start really getting a sense of
you and I was like oh [ __ ]
I think she's dealing with you not only
do I know what you're leaving here with
as happy as you are with me right now
because you listened and it worked it
could have been the worst time of your
career turned into the best you're gonna
love me even more for this one because
of the two or three years you're gonna
be just happier yeah
can I ask one more question I'm gonna
get to everybody else but we can have
you back on next week I just want to
know if you're doing for decent
Chattanooga um we will we will yes we're
just trying to figure it out but yes and
I'll be there and then we get to
high-five it out all right thank you see
ya forties is a daily digital deep dive
it's a one-day consulting product that
we do at the Sasha group which is the
agency that we had shout out to the
Sasha group let's throw up the sash
group's URL here their small business
you should check out the Sasha Greek I
know people's in the small it's really
interesting that business exploding
right now a lot of people back down
because small business is now 70 F or
250 doesn't know a consulting thing or
whatever they're doing Sasha and on the
flip side a ton of people have gone the
other way and I've gone heavy there so
if you're an SMB midsize business and
you're finally ready to do this right
especially if you work with an agency
you should definitely go to Sasha group
and hit us up let's keep this going Joe
hey Gary how you doing really well
what's cookin lad unit so to kind of
jump right in I took your advice about
nine months ago and I left a job I had
in textiles making really good money to
essentially go back into the golf
industry where golf is my passion and a
completely new position I've done like
management and sales my whole life and I
took over all the operations for the
company we're just a small premium
accessory company so my question with
that is us on top that I ended up
getting met getting I'm getting mentored
by my boss and how do you keep that
perspective of you know moving forward
knowing that there is that patience part
of it but also like this other some days
where I meant sitting here work and I
have
no idea what I'm doing just from a
standpoint of you know you don't know
what you don't know
operations to me is a completely new
field in general does it and so does it
feel right do you feel intuitively right
yeah well good yeah I mean I think it's
one of those things where I've always
loved like the sales and the management
side like coaching but the operations
I've really found a passion it's like a
yeah I really enjoy the game
yeah ops is fun uh like I'm super pumped
about this question because it's an easy
one
like don't beat yourself up yeah it's
really as simple as try and have good
intent and when you make a mistake own
it be accountable and try have good
intent accountability try like
leadership comes with accountability
yeah yeah like like just watching
business people just watching the world
like anybody who blames others at the
top is losing like you know blaming
somebody else like oh you know like my
my general manager [ __ ] it up you
hired the general manager I agree yeah
you know like so that you know like III
don't get everything stems from the top
like football owners they're like you
know my general manager Lee you hired
him my coach sucks you are the gentleman
for the hired to coach like if you're
not accountable in operations that's the
only vulnerability you have everything
else has to be good intent and effort
yeah so with that say hundreds angry on
the accountability yet something I try
to really embody because you have to be
accountable
I find myself almost like you said it's
I find myself beating myself up from the
standpoint of like I I've tried taking
your advice and you know the good and
negative comments let them kind of just
go through the same don't really think
about it
but I find myself when his people I
really look up to like my boss Mike said
that he's mentoring me in a lot of ways
when I do something like it's not the
heat he doesn't beat me up for it but
it's just like okay you did it wrong I
almost take it harder even though it is
like I'm trying I know I'm going to like
screw up so is it just essentially just
I don't know like turn your brain on
that
yeah like [ __ ] man you're so set up for
this like what did you cry and quit on
the seventh hole when you missed a
5-foot putt no okay what are you gonna
cry but she's so lucky I was waiting for
the shoe to drop that the mentor was not
giving the feedback in a way that was
palpable and then you drop that the
mentor is dropping the feedback in a
very palpable way yeah which then it you
know it's really funny when you when a
leader goes nice about it and almost
makes you want to rise up even more
right yeah let me promise you something
about your mentor based on what I'm
hearing she he he he already knows yeah
look like he knew that you didn't have
15 years of operational experience yeah
sure he already knew when I hire people
and they make all these different
mistakes I knew they didn't know how to
do it when I when I move people from a
different job into a new job and they
failed miserably I'm not upset with them
I knew there was a risk factor
he knows bro yeah he always said it he
also knows that you have the demeanor
the energy I can't even feel in this
call to [ __ ] figure it out over the
next three years it'd be [ __ ] great
at it yeah I just I think it's I yeah i
just beat myself up really quick oh
really
yeah every second you sit there and
dwell that you let him down or you're
disappointed in yourself is the second
that you're not putting in to figuring
out how to be better at it yeah yeah
it's it's true I know bro
listen promise me the second you go down
that pipe be like [ __ ] if Gary's
watching right now he punch me like you
know like like just go there go to the
don't let yourself go there it's a
complete waste of time who gives a [ __ ]
I agree
okay no it's it's great advice it's true
use what made you good at golf to focus
on this
you just can't dwell on the last putt
because if you do your whole day is
gonna be ruined
you're [ __ ] if you do that see that
was the first time in your voice that
you had conviction just convert that now
into ops bro I make mistakes every day
big ones
yeah now Gary B yeah I it's true
you got that free shipping the golf okay
got it
cuz that was the first time you're
voicing like of course I'm like right
cuz I'm the business version of that
like of course got it got it got it got
it good let's do it oh thanks Gary you
got it
[ __ ] man I love this show 9:30 7:00 in
the morning
what's good what's good what's good
Sharon
great to see you Irene lb Dennis Davis
what's that punch auntie Ron Don what's
good Jerry young thank you so much
thanks for being here come and gatok
thank you so much for being here
Mindy Vasquez hello hi oh what's up bro
hey man how you doing one of my favorite
favorite artists out here let's throw up
your website right here people need to
buy some of your art today so it's uh
Lyle Foxman calm so check out worthy but
absolutely good hanging in but actually
I want to talk about education today I
went back to teaching in public school
back in the fall and we have this big
shift now in education where it was
structured and rules and within a matter
of two to three weeks we had to go from
the classroom to online and the
classroom very structured to now where
teachers have to be more creative and
where administrators and everybody as
saying to be creative and figure it out
we are live okay so this [ __ ] worked
lau this is huge for you yes and and
it's huge for but i think and this is
where it goes into my questions is where
you know teachers now have to do this a
lot of teachers aren't comfortable doing
that because they've been for over 100
years
education has been you know for yeah for
the workers you know you don't have go
ahead so how can teachers now and the
ones that are uncomfortable take
leadership and ownership in changing a
public education system
especially when we go back they can't
they can't change the system they can
just be an individually great teacher
and play within it the biggest problem
that people understand is like the
system change is super macro some of its
on a state and national level like plus
there's a enormous percentage of people
within the teachers unions who don't
want it to change right the way they
teach is not within the system brother
the way you teach that when you change
it is outside the system that's why I've
always one mile I don't play with it in
the [ __ ] framework I play outside the
[ __ ] framework mm-hmm
so what should what should teachers be
doing now - like if you're 31 if you
have 30 you're [ __ ]
Kyle if you right now they need to be
pumping into the video classrooms the
stuff they want not reinforced to by the
curriculum because shits wild wild west
Matt yeah it is I know so teach these
kids real [ __ ] yeah cuz some [ __ ] they
have to [ __ ] memorize that's on their
[ __ ] phone that they can regurgitate
yeah cuz I had someone at you know some
of the best one-on-one interactions with
my students that I've had since starting
back up in the fall course bro because
the [ __ ] format of education in the
classroom is horseshit it just is and
then it takes great teachers to break it
within that framework and right now
you're outside that framework where you
can break you even more and the triple
the first move is a teacher that goes
into a classroom says [ __ ] this I'm
gonna [ __ ] make these kids lives
better and does what they do and then
kind of just checks the box for the
[ __ ] machine the second move is right
now now that the whole system is broken
you can do all sorts of [ __ ] and that's
where you're seeing some action the
third move your master question is very
simple 21 teachers get together and say
[ __ ] this [ __ ] find an entrepreneur and
some funding start a [ __ ] alternative
school and [ __ ] go right so we'll win
it within the public school system yeah
so so what do you think education you
know should look like I know you you
didn't like school so I think education
individual I think we should be reverse
engineering every [ __ ] child and
figuring them out and whether it's
vocational entrepreneurial or proper
structured old-school school system
lawyer
doctor like like human base not machine
based exactly but guess what that's on
parents mm-hmm you know parents funny
that you said that because a lot of the
parents are coming back now and like cuz
it was always like the teachers for and
why the parents are going oh I see I see
what you were talking about remember
what I just talked about with leadership
with the last thing yeah always always
the parents fault yeah yeah taking
second charge is your [ __ ] child
yeah cuz cuz now they're they're there
for seven hours a day for [ __ ] you
know two-thirds of the year get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ] that's
called lack of accountability by parents
yeah he was now you don't like what
they're learning at school tell them to
be like me and be a [ __ ] F student
and then teach him some [ __ ] after
school get the [ __ ] out of here
parents the [ __ ] out of your parents
yeah because now they have to sit there
with their child and help for them
Porcia they're just annoyed by their
kids that's not what they worried about
what they're worried about is they don't
want to be countable people don't want
to be accountable for [ __ ] children this
is the [ __ ] manager job their
salaries people hate to be accountable
people love to judge others for what
they suck at people don't like to look
at the [ __ ] mirror Lyle once they
don't have to look at the mirror they
get happy he's hiding come on
thank you bro alright wait everyone look
my son has one question okay okay okay
Jason Jason looks good
hi hi did you watch what Romania hell
yeah
you what would you think of the new
format i I like fans tiny fancy but they
did a good job they did the best they
can
Jason what's your favorite football team
yes good job why away to save that one
have a great day Jason give your dad a
kiss you got a good daddy all right take
care brother
all right let's see what's going on
Jesse what's good Monica Torres what's
good
Caleb ganger what's good
kenneth you could be on this service by
going to Twitter asking your question
and using the hashtag T with Gary Vee
and then somebody from Team Gary B's
Twitter account will reach out to you
and and find you and get you on the show
in the coming weeks
they've Garcia what's good what's good
well like that much work Dustin let's
keep this going
hey Gary hey Laura how are you good I'm
so excited to be on with you so I have
like a million questions so I was trying
to like complain
so I more or less want to be a writer as
my career I've had a travel blog since
2008 I wrote a book last year I kind of
did everything self-published I wanted
to learn everything I kind of want to
learn the ropes of it all so I so I love
that it's great but the sales are not
there I mean I sold like 65 Coffee is
just my own marketing and all that stuff
and what my own platform and all that
but I have a second one and I'm not sure
what to do with it because you're
worried about the sales I'm worried
about the sales but I'm also like I want
to get it out there like I want this to
really be my career and I'm not sure if
this is like because I get stuck out
like I've been doing this for 12 years
or like maybe this is something like is
this something like I should keep going
with or is it like okay well you know 12
years is a real at-bat like I'm proud of
you yeah you persevered and hung in like
this is tough to say but sometimes maybe
not there's a lot of people who want to
be a rapper and they're not good enough
there's me I want to be actors and not
good enough there's people that want to
be writers and not good enough now you
know I'm mr. optimist but I'm also mr.
practical right I don't think that has
to be a bad thing let me tell you why I
think the energy of it not working for
this for this period of time I've seen a
lot of ways sometimes becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy of not letting
it happen I believe that if you go and
try to jam on some other stuff that also
makes you happy maybe creative sometimes
that becomes the unlock all of a sudden
like I could see a scenario where you
start like sucking starting a our
podcast because ironically you also like
flowers that creativity gets going a
little something but then that triggers
the creativity you start buying yourself
two years later starting to write a
little bit and then that popped off what
you're doing yeah I mean I started
writing on elephant
how to love the different type of
writing because that I don't travel like
I used to I started this without a team
so I I'm 30 now so I've changed so much
in those than that period of time so I
actually enjoy that type of writing
where my website is now where it's I
have my travel when I can and then I
write also whatever I want to write
about but like my main thing about my
books is like how to deal with anxiety
and like how much how much free content
are you putting out on the internet with
you in video 4 I'm talking about those
subject matters I actually hate video
why I I'm just not a video person like
not you're a video person right now
you're doing extremely well I know but I
eat it domina is subconscious about your
looks
no it's not that I just don't feel like
I have like the personality we're going
I'm really dog you're wrong yeah you've
decided that for yourself subjectively
yeah yeah I mean yeah I guess it's just
it's not I guess it's uncomfortable for
me to kind of like talk to myself you
know what I mean yeah so what you could
do is actually start a zoo or or live
you could go live when there's other
people like right now Jerry Young's here
and sunny and late and that makes me
feel more comfortable like what like
Brian be like maybe I mean I I couldn't
disagree with you more I've I've done
this a ton and recognize when people are
wildly uncomfortable with video there
yeah you've arbitrarily from an insecure
place we're gonna subject the place or
an ideology place or just a random
thought place I've decided that yeah
but didn't you say to them cuz I like
followed you for so many years and I'm
like huge on your content like if that's
not your strong suit should you know
it's right that's what I guess right
that's right but I've got a problem with
that yeah
you've given writing 12 years you've
given video 0 [ __ ] days yeah I don't
know if it's your strong suit and guess
who else doesn't know you right yeah no
I got it well good cuz that's some real
[ __ ] like no good that's a fun moment
you might be right
just intuitive about this and feel like
you could definitely talk to the video
camera yeah and we just have to like you
know I'm sure it's uncomfortable for a
bit but I guess I just oh my god watch
this are you do you see any are you
watching in a way that you can see
comments somewhere yeah a little bit
real quick everybody how many of you are
doing video now like it but hated it at
first
go give me a yes I promise you're about
to be blown away so many people struggle
at first yeah like you're gonna see so
many yeses right now because like people
I mean almost everybody by the way
actually most people are not mean look
at this this is [ __ ] ridiculous yes
yeah but I guess so my other quick
question though is because I have this
second book and it's for like anxiety
for teens because I just you know a lot
of kids are young you need to make three
videos a day on tech talk about anxiety
for teens for few months and then when
you put the book out I'll [ __ ] sell
like crazy this is why we're having this
convoy yeah but do you think do you
think like there's a difference between
like self-publishing or traditional or
it doesn't matter no both win both lose
yeah I think nobody knows where the [ __ ]
you are and then when you try to sell
something it's hard to sell yeah because
the problem is is like I've gotten a lot
of feedback over the years I'm like oh I
love your stuff I love your stuff but
then I'm like but it's not showing in
sales or it's not showing in like
numbers you know I mean I'm like what
the [ __ ] am I doing wrong what you're
doing wrong is not building a personal
brand to leverage against yeah you know
well you're also crushing this video
conversation everyone's going crazy
thank you seriously don't don't do this
to yourself
yeah I want you to make two to three
[ __ ] I want you to do two to three
[ __ ] videos on tick tock a day about
anxiety and you'll [ __ ] have a look
like in three months you'll have a real
audience of young adults that they want
to buy your book yeah like we're [ __ ]
in the prime moment of being able to get
to that audience cuz of tick tock like
it's a [ __ ] gift you won't open the
[ __ ] gift it's a gift you won't write
down I know I was I was starting to play
with it a little bit and put out like
I'd put like you know I'm just messing
with it - Jordan get it out there trying
you're not putting yourself in it no not
necessarily but like I'm gonna
hosted wine I got like 400 views not
like this shit's insane so what the [ __ ]
are we doing here I don't what's your
Instagram it's travel Jersey girl but
it's spelled J erz okay bro that doesn't
find that pin that I want everybody to
how many followers do you have
I like 1850 I think good let's get that
up so there's no it's j e RZ no why no
why Dustin what Jersey are you from I'm
actually from Edison New Jersey I am
from the same town that's amazing what'd
you go to and do you know he spelled it
wrong I know he's a [ __ ] um do you
know I was in high school yeah I would I
would have went to JP Stevens oh we
didn't like you I know I'm aware but
good news I played before high school
200 and Counting so 100 in high school
okay Laura listen to me we have a huge
[ __ ] mistake
yeah all right right like we need to
talk this through no I mean listen I
mean we're all [ __ ] quarantine so I
have nothing but time so I might as well
just say [ __ ] it and try it right look
everybody Beth wants to follow you so
bad like people want to yeah listen to
me
you have your Jersey girl you can do
this we add up it going through Edison
High is way harder than [ __ ] making a
tick-tock well I also because I feel
like I resonate with you so much because
we're from Jersey and I knew you were
from Jersey somehow because that like
the curse thing in like the Jersey 'no
son like not he's in Jersey but like I
also feel like that could I'm sure
you've had the same thing where it's
like I you shouldn't curse so much I'm
like you but yes they're like that's me
[ __ ] them I hacked Lee I promise you you
be fully you on tick-tock three times a
day really get into the culture of
tick-tock what kind of videos make and
you [ __ ] Laura listen to me
these young girls and guys need you yeah
don't do this for me
don't do this for you know do that for
them maybe I mean this do for them
yeah now you have 2045 followers on
Instagram what's your tick-tock um it's
the same thing Travel Jersey
all across the board twitter twitter
saying do you have a youtube i do not
but i have you don't make good Maus no
no I tried back in the day I tried and I
was like now [ __ ] that I'm not about it
listen honey yeah
listen to me I'm telling you this is
this this moment was for this yeah yeah
Korona happens so we could talk I agree
so good yeah you're [ __ ] Jersey girl
you should not have a problem with this
I mean that I now do this no tell me
some real [ __ ] tell me why you're not
doing it is there anything I'm not
thinking about like weird stalker
boyfriend
[ __ ] you know bad I'm trying I'm being
really real whatever I want you to win
so I want to know it's just like
unconscious it's just uncomfortable
I think I think intuitively I think you
can break through yeah and I honestly
think it's just like a like and Laura
real quick before you finished yeah cuz
I want everybody hears I swear to God I
don't do this all the time there's a lot
of cause I do there's a lot of people
interact with I don't push them all the
time
because I don't always think they can
there's some weird [ __ ] out there
they're not good they're not good but I
really think you can do this yeah I mean
because I want like with my books too
cuz I struggle with anxiety too so it's
just like it's very personal to me so I
just feel like between I need you to be
more vulnerable in your videos then and
put me out tik-tok help these kids yeah
okay
I'm telling you right now you can't
imagine how huge you can get on tik-tok
with this truth with this jersey ness
yeah like once you get going like yeah I
talked to somebody the other day and
she's a little bit more of a comfortable
content creator he literally took her
for hours
she DM me she's like you [ __ ] change
the game for me already I'm like voice
impressions different things are simple
[ __ ] going on there yeah I think you can
find your spot I'm telling you alright
unbelievable are you gonna do it or you
like [ __ ] right now I will I mean
I'm not gonna lie and you know I am very
uncomfortable about trying to do it but
I'm gonna play with it and see and just
I mean I have nothing to lose at this
what's gonna happen you're like [ __ ]
you're like best friend from college I
mean like all you [ __ ] suck a dick
talks about that so listen then
that's what I believe like I'm
systematically going through the cliche
reasons one doesn't
yeah I'm personally no I'm not stuck I
almost feel like like you just [ __ ]
decide it yeah
yeah all right things change right yeah
you can undecide yeah
Lord do this please yeah do me a favor
promise me this because everyone's
following you right now and sorry
they're gonna tell me tomorrow that you
[ __ ] I know yeah it's over yeah [ __ ]
now we've got everyone's watching hey
everybody's following everyone's
following you now so tomorrow they're
all gonna be back cuz I'm back tomorrow
I'm about to wrap up here at 9 a.m. I
can't wait to see all of you back we're
all following you
yeah I'm gonna put my whole team on it
no Brent right I need you to make two or
three tic TOCs today and two or three
and make an Instagram video where you
just talk about things okay you can do
this I'm gonna comfortable as [ __ ] but
okay I like that because the most
uncomfortable is [ __ ] [ __ ] usually leads
to the best [ __ ] yeah
by the way they need to hear you yeah
you can help them do you understand that
if you get serious about tick-tock
you're gonna save a child's life
yeah I know I mean it's well you're not
seeing [ __ ] with 65 [ __ ] books sold
on [ __ ] Amazon Laura well yeah you
are you lookin at me do you understand
right now yeah so here's what's really
gonna happen listen to me you know one
tick-tock you go [ __ ] ham you're
gonna build a real [ __ ] audience I
promise you I can feel it with my whole
[ __ ] soul mm-hmm those hey you're
gonna save kids lives in that content be
a bunch of them I'm gonna buy books when
she's gonna make you happy cuz you've
been wanting to be a [ __ ] writer for
your whole life and there's gonna be a
[ __ ] self-fulfilling prophecy of the
[ __ ] good versus you decided you
don't do it and nothing [ __ ] happens
right I mean in those 64 books you know
[ __ ] a half of the people that bought
it yeah yeah
two thirds yeah okay Lou bought [ __ ]
20 of them mm-hmm so let's [ __ ] get
series here Laura you guys tick-tock to
the [ __ ] face
okay I mean I don't even know what the
hell I would say but I'm gonna tell you
what to do right now okay
you're gonna go in right now
hang up and watch three four hours of
tick-tock literally watch click the
trending topics go in your feed for you
page and just watch watch watch watch
you're gonna see trends even the commode
everyone's doing this ok my way of
talking about that through the lens of
anxiety I'm gonna make this video you're
gonna [ __ ] figure it out I believe in
you you're creative okay alright alright
well thank you so much all right thank
you soon
what an episode hope everybody enjoyed
it now go to speak to 1500 executives in
a humongous company so I'm gonna go into
that stream some old-school software
none of this tremendous stream yard
anyway real quick last pitch I got you
dead last pitch put it up right here
whine text today if I'm bringing you
value this coming for me it's not
empathy it's for pops for my dad who I
love the most
please sign up for white X today today
50 50 plus dollar Pinot Noir that's
bonkers for under 25 bucks a bottle
it's gonna sell out probably within 30
minutes so when you get the text do it
please sign up for wine text if you do
when you get the confirmation thank you
scream post it on Twitter I want to
follow you as I thank you I love you
Dustin thank you so much for the ones
and twos we've got tomorrow full time
good show today Dustin very good show
for one hour of gun why not in there
that last one huh yeah that last one huh
Dustin are you signed up for my text I
am but I don't drink wine well then do
to unsubscribe and I don't I don't need
to [ __ ] pay for you cost money I know
I know
[ __ ] just hoping one day maybe get the
[ __ ] everybody
you